[Music]
let's go out to
kate across the border in ontario what's
up kate
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call of course what's up
well i called into the ramsay show in
june and i talked to dave and rachel
during that call some boundary issues i
have with my parents came up and at the
end of that call rachel suggested i dial
up to honey so that's what i'm doing
there it once again i'm bailing out
rachel cause i'm just kidding love it
yeah i'd love to hear it tell me what's
going on
thank you in 2017 my parents gifted
myself and my husband
a down payment for our home it was very
generous they wanted to bless us fast
forward to april 20 21 we started the
baby steps now we're on baby step 4 and
6.
in december 2021 my grandmother passed
away and left me some money
my mother who's the executor of the
estate asked me what i want to do with
the money i told her my husband and i
would like to use the money to complete
baby step six to pay off her mortgage
she told me
she wants me to use the money for home
repairs and to put into my specific tax
advantage retirement accounts she wants
the money to quote
remain mine in the event of a divorce
she also said that if
we pay off the house with this
inheritance money
quote my father's family will have paid
for almost the whole thing your husband
should pay for half
sounds
sounds like your mom is a huge fan of
your husband
oh you know what and the thing is she
actually loves him so much
did your is your mom divorced did she
get left
no my parents are together i believe my
dad was divorced prior to his
relationship with my mom but i okay
that's i only know that from a passing
conversation that i've heard in
childhood
uh maybe one day
ask your dad that question that'd be
cool to know just where you come from
that seems like
family 101.
um okay let me let me give some uh some
insider baseball
to our listeners here
um so
kate is trying to pay off all of her
debts
right um so she found herself did you
have credit cards student loan debt and
all the stuff owned cars loans and all
that kind of stuff
we had a car loan and um
uh student debt from my husband's
doctorate degree and it was all paid off
and we're so excited okay awesome
congratulations
is done sweet so the average listener um
uh listening to this
there is a direct correlation to your
mental well-being and your relational
health and even your physical health and
this idea of safety and the idea of
autonomy if your body knows you're not
safe and the body knows you're not in
control of your life
it will cascade stress hormones through
you all the time and we know from
genetics and we know from behavioral
neurobiology and we know from
experiences people respond in a number
of different ways whether it's anxiety
and depression all these different
things to these stress responses stress
response
and one of the chief stressors of our
time and if you look at a map like a i'm
sorry a graph and you were to chart
the increase of debt in the united
states over the last hundred years it's
it
puddle it puts along puts along and then
it shoots straight up
you could lay over that mental health
diagnostics you could lay over that
all different kinds of of maladies in
our culture and i am convinced in fact
i'm working with some phd students on a
study
so i can i i can prove it there is a
direct correlation
direct causal correlation between the
amount you owe on things and your
well-being
and the problem is we live in a culture
that sells debt as a way of being it's
the air we breathe it also says that um
no i don't go down a rabbit hole there
so um
my friend dave ramsey's got a plan how
to get out of debt right here's how you
just do this and here's how you free
yourself and your family and quite
honestly you really do a lot of work on
your mental health and relational health
so that's where kate finds herself
and so what was the original
like
when you were getting married and your
grandmother was going to bless y'all
with a house down payment how much was
it
my parents
gave us a house down payment of thousand
dollars okay so your parents gave you 50
grand
and then what what's the inheritance
that you've received from your
grandmother
um
166 i've received about half of it due
to just a state red tape i should
receive the remaining half-ish in about
a year or in the next year okay
so to the to the listener
there's going to be a debate between
whether do we inherit i mean do we
invest this money so it grows while at
the same time paying mortgage interest
rate and then someone's gonna say but it
could grow at ten percent and your
mortgage is only at three percent so
you're actually if you pay your mortgage
off you're being stupid because that
money could earn seven percent you can
earn that gap and blah blah blah
here's what i am
hell-bent on on the show
is solving for freedom
solving for peace
and in my personal life
you can take the seven percent
and set it on fire as far as i'm
concerned because i don't want to owe
anybody anything because if i don't owe
anybody anything my body goes
and most of us especially our parents
and families have never exhaled because
we've always had a car payment or a
student loan or a home payment and
that's why people get bananas to pay
everything off even if the math might be
different right it might work out
differently
so you were saying kate i
you and your husband are choosing
freedom
not some
not some imaginary return in the market
that may or may not happen down the road
right
exactly okay so let me first say if i
was in your seat your situation
i would do exactly the same thing you're
doing 100 to the letter
okay so my advice is not mathematical my
advice is here's what me and my wife
would do in our home
and then what i would do is i would
spend the next 20 years with no house
payment no
car payments no nothing payments
and you want to talk about wealth
accumulation
sister it's going to pile up in a wild
way okay
so
here's the bigger boundary issue um and
i'm i'm going to be kind of direct with
you okay i don't wanna talk bad about
people that love you and that you love
but i'm gonna be pretty straightforward
with you is that cool i i appreciate the
directness thank you dr john your mom
does not get a vote your grandmother did
not leave your mom a bunch of money with
a few ideas for how she could spend it
she left it to you
and she left it to you because she
trusts you
if you were a drug addict you you were
struggling with addiction you were
struggling with all whatever you
violated your grandmother's values she
would not have put a hundred and sixty
six thousand dollars in your pocket
and say i agree i trust you do with what
you wish
now when it comes to some arbitrary
mathematical whatever she's saying about
your husband is dumb that's just dumb
um here's the reality you've gone all in
with this guy do you all have kids
no we don't are you gonna have kids
someday or no
no i don't think it's in the cards for
us okay so you're not gonna have kids so
y'all it's just ride or die you too
right
exactly and i love him and they've
they've known him a long time and they
love him too she's just she's very
concerned about
like my personal safety yep and i think
she equates this this money being quote
mine
to my safety gotcha and what i would say
is when you get married and this is a
very unpopular man i'm just gonna i'm
gonna get all kinds of great youtube
comments on this one i'm telling you uh
kate don't read the comments on when
this episode comes out
oh no sir if you go it all in with
somebody and you say i'm gonna get
married to you then your stuff is his
stuff
and your cancer diagnosis is y'all's
cancer diagnosis
and your inheritance becomes y'all's
inheritance and his debt becomes y'all's
debt y'all are in this thing together
as a single entity and when you hedge
your
relationships
the big one that i get a lot of grief
for is having separate checking accounts
yes we're gonna make humans together yes
we're gonna we're gonna buy a house
together we're gonna do all these things
but i get my money and he is his money
that's a hedge because i don't fully
trust him and if you're not all in and
he's not all in
then your marriage is is going to have
it's going to have a hole in the boat
right the only way it works is go all in
and what does that mean when you go all
in you know what can happen you can get
hurt really really bad
so i'm also gonna be honest with you
there's a chance you pay off this house
and you pay off the mortgage and you'll
pop a bottle of champagne and he files
for divorce the next day
yes that could happen
right that's that could happen it could
it could happen and i i said to her in a
conversation i think
if that did happen you know the next day
or in five years i think the hurt i
would have would not be healed by
half of 160 yeah it wouldn't be healed
by 83 000
yes exactly
yes and yes
and i think that's the other important
thing to remember here is you've got
eighty three thousand dollars so let's
take say he takes half
takes half of your house and half of the
retirement half of the whatever you're
still not starving right no
um you'll still have your needs met and
you'll have a
a place where you can grieve because it
would be a mess because not because he
just took your money
but he took your trust in your soul all
these things that hopefully aren't ever
going to happen right
right exactly but following your mom's
logic up the up the trail
the next step is you need to keep
something for you
and the next step is you need to protect
yourself because you might get hurt
and the next step is you shouldn't have
got married in the first place because
that could lead to hurt
and then the next step is you shouldn't
even date because dating might open your
heart and when you open your heart you
can get hurt you see what i'm saying
like if you follow the logic all the way
up there's nowhere to stop
the only place to stop
all in right so
the best
sometimes i give advice here on
situations that i've not experienced um
what i haven't experienced this but i'm
telling you 100 if my wife if if
both of my grandmothers have passed away
if i had gotten a check for 166 000 from
either one of my grandparents it would
have gone directly to paying my house
off
i feel very comfortable with the
financial part of it it's more just the
relational part that
if and when she asks
what did you do with that
pile of money yeah so i just i here's
the response you don't want an ugly
situation thank you you don't get to
choose the ugly situation she might
and there's not a lot you can do on this
end except be respectful and treat her
with dignity
and say i'm doing what i think is best
for me and my family
if she chooses to throw a temper tantrum
or chooses to act like a child because
she didn't get her way
that's a choice she's made
that's a grenade she's thrown not you
that makes sense
it does make sense so at the end of the
day i think a wise conversation it
sounds like you and your mom have a
pretty good relationship is that fair
we do we're close we talk lots you know
we have we have disagreements we've had
fights but pretty normal mother-daughter
stuff so don't get sucked into the this
is a math problem conversation because
it's not
this is a mom who loves her daughter
and this is a mom who's either
experienced it or has friends who's
experienced it or watches a lot of
you know late night tv
and
doesn't it
doesn't want her daughter to get hurt
and the fact is you went all in you got
married
and so you
are vulnerable and your husband's
vulnerable and the chance you all can
hurt each other is real
and the chance you can love each other
and get something better out of your
life than you could have ever imagined
is also real
and so i here's the conversation i would
have or let me just be honest here's a
conversation i have had when me and my
parents have had disagreements
you raised a good son
and you raised me to be thoughtful and
wise and smart and to get seek wise
counsel
trust me with the decision i'm making on
my life
and at least in my life every time my
parents have exhaled and said you're
right
thank you for that that's very
thoughtful and respectful and i think i
think she might respond well to that
yeah and she can give you a hard time
and you can tell her with a smile on
your face if he leaves me
and takes half of everything
i will pay for dinner and i will i will
make a cake that says you were right
and i mean like i will i'll acknowledge
it
i love to bake but i hope not to bake
that one
yes that would be not a big one um i do
know this is a delicate situation i do
think you are incredibly wise
and i think you are being a great
steward of this money uh is my by the
way is my is
is that what dave said to please tell me
i'm right
oh absolutely absolutely okay
yes
um good that's exactly what dave and
rachel said and what dave and george
said in a previous call and i feel again
i feel very comfortable with the
financial aspect of the decision
it makes sense i've weighed options but
this is the choice that feels right for
myself and my husband yeah
so
lean into your mom tell her hey you did
a good job
you raised a good smart wise daughter
and i realized that marriage can hurt me
hurt me real bad
and marriage can be incredible too
and um
i'm gonna i'm gonna choose freedom this
time with this incredible gift we're
choosing freedom
and your gift plus um grandma's gift
gives us incredible freedom and now me
and my husband can um
[Music]
put all of our money towards
giving all of our money towards saving
all of our money towards
um
joy in our home and in other people's
homes and now we're gonna be free
and maybe for the first time in a
generation we're gonna be free we're
gonna be free we're gonna be free
and um
man what a blessing it's pretty cool
uh
man i hope i have granddaughters like
you
i really do